[Music]
hey head of the wedding of my sister yes
I am so where's your fiance wait is this
him hey I'm Ben I was for hall pass on
your break wow you are a child it's
pretty long flight do you want anything
from the front of the boat I'm all good
on Creatine and smelled like insecurity
nothing small about me what
the that's the jerk poopy got with when
she was on a break from Jonathan I could
never be with someone like him this girl
is a
disastrous
we're going to our wedding
sorry what's it going stranger what's
going on over there they dated she
crushed his heart that man does not have
a
heart no way honey look who's here who
is that my ex Jonathan my parents have
been trying to get us back together he's
like a son to us maybe we should just
tell everyone we're together what it
would solve that problem for me and you
clearly want Margaret she seesure with
me she wants what she can't have there's
no way we can convince anyone we
actually like each other you know I
still think about that night we spent
together shut up no I'm
serious no matter how it ended it still
pretty
amazing convincing enough let's do
it honey here he is oh no I'm with Ben
so is it like we just got together or
we've been saking around let's just be
affectionate Showtime permission to put
my left hand on your right buttock
granted not a magic
lamp hey little guy God damn it see you
tonight we have to kick it up a not nice
touch nice
TR oh no no it's going to be hot when
are you ever going to learn [__] it it's
fine Titanic me are they watching are
they doing Titanic they're gone show's
over oh my
god do you have a mo or something but
no what theu what the what the one might
be in
you I'm good it's probably a better way
to check than what I did it's a bad idea
right what did we miss what did we miss
[__] it it's
fine